[Music]
a new art exhibit unveiled here in new
york city on friday it's a monument to
nellie bly regarded by many as america's
first investigative journalist
through her trailblazing career she
uncovered abuse and injustice and gave
voice to the voiceless the installation
is not far from the scene of one of her
greatest triumphs and it's created by a
sculptor trying to address an imbalance
in our public art
christina raffini has the story
on the north most end of roosevelt
island a sliver of soil between
manhattan and queens
nelly bly keeps watch
it is a puzzle it's the girl puzzle i
want people to experience it as a puzzle
to walk through see the reflections of
the faces see the puzzle pieces of the
faces
these seven foot faces are the creation
of sculptor amanda matthews
a tribute to bly an investigative
journalist who became one of the
island's most famous and fearless
residents she didn't just try to read
about and understand people who exist in
the margins she put herself
in those same situations yes physically
at risk emotionally at risk in 1887 bly
went undercover as an inmate at the
island's asylum her report 10 days in a
mad house revealed the deplorable
treatment of women in the facility
prompting outrage and reform i knew that
nellie bly was such a larger than life
figure that we needed to do something
larger than life and not big it's pretty
big yes
progressively larger spheres reflect the
impact of her reporting as well as the
faces of four other women
from diverse or marginalized communities
the more i read of her work the more i
could not separate it from
women i know and i thought how timely
this work was and still is
this installation is one of only a
handful of public monuments in the
united states depicting women
the faces took 18 months to make at
matthew's studio in kentucky where a few
years ago she made a startling statue
related discovery the only sculpture
honoring a female
on public owned land in the state of
kentucky
was a confederate general's horse the
horse yes and i literally burst into
tears they were angry tears i was mad
about that but next year after a lot of
lobbying her sculpture of educator
nettie depp will be installed at the
state capital
women's history didn't show up in our
history books the same as men it's not
written down as much it's not portrayed
as much so we have to reach back into
history
find this information bring it into the
21st
century let's give a warm welcome to
shelton hayes that's something shelton
haynes the head of the roosevelt island
operating corporation also supports
why honoring women you know there's so
many women that contributed so many
different things that are
underrepresented and as you can see here
it shows that diverse background it
shows their contributions
the faces surrounding bly
young and old
asian and african american are all women
matthews knows personally like 98 year
old miyoko chambliss who at age 18 was
sent to a japanese internment camp when
nellie bly said i saw the look of
distress
on my companions faces as we came closer
to the island and saw the long stone
buildings i couldn't see anything else
other than the pictures miyoko had shown
me
matthew's two daughters are also
depicted including natalie fields so
your face behind you looks a little
different my face is aged forward
because not only are women rarely
recognized in sculpture but older women
are hardly ever recognized in sculpture
and i'm part of the queer community and
you don't see representation of older
queer women
the back of the sculptures are engraved
with a quote from bly's writings that
inspire the selection of each subject
the quote is while i live i hope luckily
for me this quote is very short i happen
to have it tattooed on my inner arm
luckily it fit in just the five words
but i want
people in my community
to know that someone out there is
speaking for them is trying their
hardest to represent
a little bit of our community and that's
something that i've never seen
and didn't
expect to see
in my lifetime
the face of female resilience is
represented by keusha bacon brown
growing up did you ever see a sculpture
a public work that made you think of
your life for yourself at all
not ever
she overcame tragedy after the death of
her infant daughter
this installation is spiritual it's not
just faces it's not just concrete and
bronze it's a spirit of of love a spirit
of peace there's hope here
and
i just want everyone to respect it
so while these women never met nellie
bly they can see themselves in her words
conversations about lived experiences
about intersectionality about where we
belong and in what categories other
people see us and in what categories we
see ourselves
needs to be part of that nuanced
discussion about where do women fit in
and where are these new spaces where we
can now inhabit
roosevelt island seems to be one of them
seems to be
for cbs saturday morning christina
raffini new york
love everything about that installation
and we talk about this so often but it's
raising that awareness of stories you do
not know of marginalized communities
period and representation matters you
see them talk about her age forward and
celebrating that too
it's very important the sculptures are
just
striking